comedy central has made it official
it'll soon be the end of the line for
daniel tasha's irreverent comedy series
tosh.0 the long-running show debuted in
2009 and was a major hit with fans
flocking to hear tosh
known for his sarcastic black humor
ridicule the latest internet meme or
fail video
i've seen many idiots in the 18 years
have hosted tosh.0 but this guy might be
the dumbest
in its first season the show immediately
shot to number one in its time slot for
the valuable marketing demo of man ages
18 to 24.
tosh soldiered on for another 11 seasons
and there were even plans for more
before the covet 19 pandemic halted
production
the series received an unprecedented
four season renewal order
comedy central's decision came hot on
the heels of the less surprising
decision to also pull the plug on drunk
history
according to slash film tosh.0 will
return to finish its upcoming 12th
season which will push the series over
the 300 episode mark
a sure sign that the bingeable internet
focused comedy show will live on in
syndication for years to come
many viewers were understandably
suspicious of comedy central's about
face on the show given its popularity
and relatively small budget
slash film speculated that it may have
something to do with comedy central's
parent company
viacom cbs and its financial struggles
more than the show itself
tosh.0 appears to be a casualty of
broader trends in the industry generally
and a concerted restructuring over at
viacom cbs specifically
the decision to reverse course on an
earlier order certainly speaks to the
shifts that have only been accelerated
by the industry-wide production shutdown
caused by the pandemic comedy central's
ongoing commitment to tosh as creator
also suggests that it isn't really about
him or the show
it's been said amongst hollywood execs
over at comedy central that you
shouldn't show a guy
resetting prime numbers for three hours
on television
but i'm unconventional at the time of
the called off four season renewal
comedy central also inked a first look
deal for tosh that would include
new scripted and unscripted series that
could either feature tosh as a performer
or taken behind the camera as an
executive producer
news of tosh.0's cancellation was not
accompanied by any suggestion that
comedy central
intends to kill the rest of tosh's deal
so we may still see new projects from
him in the future
but if tosh wants to increase his
chances on getting one picked up
all signs suggest that he should be
thinking about animation
live action comedy series like tosh.0
and drunk history don't
neatly fit into the comedy central
lineup anymore where the programming
landscape is vastly different from what
it was a decade ago
cable channels have struggled to retain
their audiences in the era of peak
streaming tv and comedy central is one
of the many networks that has had to
find ways to adapt
comedy central's approach appears to be
a move away from live-action comedy
series
and toward adult animation aside from
network stalwart the daily show
aquafina is nora from queens will be the
only live
action series left after tosh.0 makes
its final bout
comedy central is also deep into
development on reboots of the 90s
animated classics beavis and butthead
and ren and stimpy not to mention
a spin-off of mtv's darya called jody
the future at comedy central certainly
appears to be animated
given that the network earlier punted
other live-action shows
such as south side and the other two to
hbo max
tosh at least has kept his trademark
sense of humor in the face of this grim
verdict against his show
in response to news of his cancellation
he said i look forward to doing an
animated reboot of my show on mtv in 25
years
are you happy your hollywood parasites
broke me
fans may not have to wait that long
though slash film is reporting that a
group of tosh.0 executive producers
are currently shopping the series to
other distributors including streaming
platforms
which would be a web redemption if you
will it's easier than ever for canned
series to jump chip to new platforms
thanks to the
infinite formatting and scheduling
possibilities offered by streaming
giants like netflix
hulu and amazon prime video not to
mention relative newcomers hbo
max peacock and disney plus while we
can't necessarily imagine tosh.0
streaming alongside the live-action
mulan
any of the other platforms would make a
comfortable home
barring some unforeseen intervention the
final episodes of tosh.0 are due to
begin airing on september 15th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you